[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
or is that particular Dear John Hank
it's a comedy podcast in which two
brothers answer your questions give heed
abuse advice and review all the week's
news from both Mars and AFC Wimbledon
John how are you feeling I mean I'm very
sad but I'm also extremely put off by
your way of talking right now it should
be noted this is our third attempt to
record the intro and we keep having to
abandon it because Hank is using his
spooky voice and then it wasn't saying
kooky voice I changed it from spooky to
more like to more like announcer of of
like a chilled 1990s children television
show mmm it wasn't it just came across
as spooky again just a different kind of
spooky definite maybe creepy yeah
but I'm sad because my dog has died and
it's I'm glad I went so hard in the
beginning John so yeah would take you so
long to get to where we're at now I'm
sorry yeah yeah well thank you I am I am
very sad Sara and I are really sad the
kids are sad and we miss Willy and he
was a very good dog and and it's tough I
mean we only had him for ten years you
know he didn't have as long a life as we
would have liked but hopefully he had a
good dog life it was just a very hard
day saying goodbye to him one of the
hardest so much harder than I thought it
was going to be to be honest with you
and I have to say that I'm very grateful
a number of people have made donations
to the Indianapolis Humane Society in
his memory which is so kind and
thoughtful of them and not even
something that even crossed our mind
that might happen and so I want to say
thank you to those people and and one of
those people Charlotte from England sent
in a Auden Ash poem along with her
donation and so I thought I might read
to you that short poem by Ogden Nash
about dogs there's a lot of great poems
about dogs but this one is short and
sweet it goes like this
the truth I do not stretch or shove when
I state that the dog is full of love
I've also found by actual tests a wet
dog is the lovingest we have had cameo
for so so long and she has always been
such a healthy healthy animal that I am
terrified of her ever getting sick and
need her in my life
ya know I mean it's pets become part of
the family and and it's very hard to
imagine the world without them I mean
that the house feels so quiet and empty
now it really is it really is something
but let's move on Hank we have a very
important question that we have to
answer before all the other questions
it's the last question in the roundup
that rosianna sent you but by far the
most important so if you could just
scroll down Hank it's question number 27
do you see yes mmm it's from Rosa
yes asks dear Hank and John what our
pop-tarts think just all caps there's
one piece of punctuation a period at the
end we got several versions of this
question but this is by far my favorite
version what are pop-tarts thank a lot
of people out there don't know what
pop-tarts are it turns out Hank and I of
course thought that pop-tarts were like
different taxes you know the third
unavoidable institution of humanity
right they were they were invented along
with fire deaths like pop-tarts and fire
yeah the stuff that first first they
made the pop-tart and they were like we
need to toast this cheese the thing I
loved most about this question is that
immediately upon being asked it I
realized that I have no real answer like
I don't know I cannot describe for you
what a pop-tart is exactly well I mean
okay so Rosa imagine if you will a
ravioli that's made of bread mm-hmm but
very thin and and very like Whaley bread
mm-hmm and instead of cheese its
strawberry jam right that's one way of
approaching it I was also
thinking it's kind of like a cream
filled donut only extremely flattened
and whereas donuts are sort of like soft
dough this is a very hard dough and
instead of game there's fake
strawberries inside well it could be
clear there are jelly-filled doughnuts
as well
oh great point Hank I just hate them so
that's probably why they didn't cross my
mind and the and the the Jam is very dry
it's a very dry paste of strawberry or
and they also have other things and
oftentimes they're drizzled with like I
got icing a hard like a hardened icing
and then there's like apple cinnamon
kind that's I don't know if there's
actually any Apple in it but it's
definitely sugar cinnamon and then on
the on the top there's a further sugary
cinnamon drizzle on top you know they
are they are mass-produced pastries that
are meant to be put into a bread toaster
if you have one if you have those I
don't know if that's sort of a uniquely
American thing I don't know that I've
seen a lot of bread toasters in other
parts of the world or you stick them in
and you push the little button and then
I pop up and I guess that's why they're
called pop-tarts because they're tarts
that pop I never put that together until
just now do you know what they were
originally called no country squares
country squares yep can i oh they'll hmm
in country squares oh yeah quite quite
oh and but maybe we're country squares a
thing before they were before that like
something that people made No okay the
answer is that no that was the brand
that Kellogg's created was country
squares and they were like no no no no
no no no pop-tarts and I guess the idea
is just like a pastry that you can fit
in a toaster is kind of the whole
purpose right that's exactly right
as of 2014 sales of pop-tarts have
increased for 32 consecutive years I
think the economy gets bigger the
economy gets smaller we go through the
greatest recession since the Great
Depression and the one
that doesn't stop growing is the overall
market for pop-tarts
is there a cryptocurrency based on
pop-tarts yes
starting today yes yes what it Hank that
is a great idea pop-tart coin popcorn or
pop-tart I think Parkway might I liked
art art coins better tart coin country
square coin
that's a good one too because it sounds
reliable because it's got the word
country in it and square and I feel like
square is a shape that you can count on
it's not one of the stronger shapes
actually you build things out of squares
you find pretty quick that you you
prefer you might prefer an arch well
Hank I mean we're talking about
cryptocurrencies so I think it's country
square coin is a fantastic
cryptocurrency name and we've just
copyrighted it and trademarked it and
I've got country square coin calm taken
plus country square coin biz that's a
little we're gonna actually used to run
the cryptocurrency Gotti's adat vis for
your seventh rate cryptocurrency so
excited and basically the only thing you
can purchase with our cryptocurrency is
pop-tarts but the good news is that
pop-tarts only increase in value right
they are tied to the value of a pop-tart
that's right so so what like yeah the
idea is whether the whether the pop-tart
value goes up or down that the coin is
tied directly to that which removes the
volatility of cryptocurrency we've
revolutionized the world yes Hank
you've done it I've done it finally a
proper million dollar idea million ha I
settled for not not less than trillion
dollar ideas speaking of trillion dollar
ideas right before we started this
podcast Hank told me the best idea he's
ever had and I really want to pitch it
to you guys um it's not dumb it's really
good Hank and I think a lot of your
ideas are don't do it are you gonna tell
people about it
do you mind cuz it's such a good idea
and I know that a lot of your ideas are
dumb and you pitched them to me and you
think there's such good ideas and I'm
like that's the stupidest thing I've
ever heard
this is a properly great million dollar
idea funny because I just tell them I
came at it from the perspective of it
being a dumb idea that I love it's
brilliant I I love everything about this
idea here's the idea Hank and I do a 260
video series in which each video is
devoted entirely to one second of the
music video for the song des besito
so every episode we look at one second
of despots Ito's video and we analyze it
in excruciating detail and that's the
videos I don't know if everybody is
aware but des Patito is about to hit
five billion views on YouTube it is the
most viewed YouTube video of all time by
a kind of a fairly wide margin at this
point and and I feel like it deserves
more cultural commentary and criticism
and I will be totally frank with you I
watched this music video over the course
of two hours probably a total of six
times so I got pretty into it I got I
went pretty deep into my curiosity about
the craft of this really now that I've
spent some time with it amazing music
like creation like both in terms of the
song but but in terms of the video as
well I found a number of surprising
things that I wanted to share with the
world john has modified my idea slightly
I wanted to just do it in a sort of
marathon livestream where I went but
then John was like there are 364
thousand frames so that might take more
time than you expect yeah Hank wanted to
go frame by frame I just think that's
too extreme I think the right amount of
critical attention to pay to the DES
Pacita music video is 260 videos
yeah I think that you could say a lot
about I think you say a lot about
society through this project John of
course you could anything that's that's
as close to the center of pop culture as
this music video is if you pay the
proper amount of attention to it which
is way too much it gets really
interesting so I love this idea I think
it's the best idea you've ever had let's
move on to another question from our
listeners all right well if anybody has
any thoughts on this idea let me know
and I'm looking forward to that this
question comes from anonymous dear Hank
and John I was raised in a religious
family where we prayed before every meal
I'm no longer religious but it feels
weird to not do something to signify the
beginning of a meal especially when
there are other people over could you
please help me come up with a
non-religious beginning of the meal
tradition Thank You anonymous we have
something like this in our family yeah
well I mean in our extended family like
dad still does that does the grace Mikey
yeah I still I actually still say the
grace that dad says yeah because
whatever if it ain't broke what's the
dad Grace a bless us O Lord and these
thy gifts are about to receive from thy
bounty through Christ our Lord
yeah yep yep that's the one but the
thing that we do in our family in
addition to running through that
sentence as quickly as is humanly
possible the other thing that we do is
we have a tradition where we say what
we're grateful for we'll just go around
the table and say what we're grateful
for that day and nobody is allowed to
copy anybody else and only Alice is
allowed to say the same thing over and
over again so that tradition I assume
will be broken we tried hard to make it
so that everybody has to say something
different every day but Alice is only
grateful for one thing which is mommy
well it's hard to take that away if
ahran if Orin would ever ever say that
he liked the moment when Orin says like
I love you or thank you or just any kind
of recognition beyond the you know sort
of like physical cues that he he likes
us I have a really hard
I'm imagining that I will ever ask any
of anything of him ever again well let
me tell you you will yeah that's really
good there was a there's a fun time when
the our two families were hanging out
and Katherine and I do a sort of like
not all the time but I often do a
similar thing where we sort of like take
a moment to recognize the people and and
animals that were involved in the
creation of our food to at least sort of
recognize like thanks to the people who
created this and the animals who died
for it
and we did that once when we were with
your family and to Sarah green come on
and cheekily said I see you fish which
is what people say after they kill
people and kill animals and eat them in
the movie Avatar
yeah I remember yeah and we were like
hey yeah but but I think gratefulness is
something that I am super in favor of
like bringing like intentionally
bringing into my life more not just
because like I think that it's accurate
like that there are lots of like reasons
to be thankful to lots of people and
things all the time but also there's
been research done that people who keep
gratefulness journals like who are
required by researchers to like write
down things that they're grateful for
are happier like have have more positive
emotions so yeah well I definitely am a
big believer in intentional izing things
like gratefulness so that is our advice
that's a little bit of proper advice in
this advice podcast this next question
comes from Elinor who writes Dear John
and Hank on the internet I once came
across an article that claimed that
Millennials can't afford housing because
they spend too much on avvocato toast my
siblings and I thought this was crazy
because avocados and bread just aren't
that expensive we then got to thinking
would it be more expensive to buy a
house or to build a house made out of
avocado toast sincerely the toast is
with the mostest Eleanor a good
John first a piece of commentary you can
tell that avocados happened after we
stopped living in the same house because
we say that word differently
yeah actually even as I was saying it I
kept thinking I'm saying this word weird
so it's possible that I just say or that
this was just the one time and you
usually say avocado but in any case it's
fine to say avocado or avocado or ever
you want to say it because it's we
understand you and it's a wonderful
delicious food my first comment on this
article mm-hmm is that there are so many
articles on the internet right now that
are designed to make people angry and
make people click on them because they
are angry and then in exchange for
turning your non mood into a mood of
anger you have given the writer of that
article money yeah uh-huh yeah basically
though to be clear the writer of the
article most likely isn't receiving the
money though a piece of it right is
being right that's a great point being
thanked by their labor is also being
exploited and I are avocados inexpensive
John because I feel like they're not I
feel like they are a a expensive food
you know that moment in 30 rock where
Jack Donaghy is trying to negotiate the
price of something and he says say
you're buying a gallon of milk which
costs $12 I think if you and I get into
the business of trying to debate whether
avocados are expensive we're going to be
in a jack Donaghey milk cost $12
situation fortunately for you I've
already calculated about how much money
one slice of avocado toast costs it's
around a dollar 65 that seems cheap to
me well remember you don't use a whole
avocado to make avocado toast
ouais where I go they do they give you
two piece to two pieces of bread and I'm
pretty sure I'm eating a whole avocado
when I get avocado toast and it's real
good they put like cracked pepper and
salt and they butter the bread before
they put the avocado on and I'm
my god that seems under seven for it I'm
so into it and then I feed a little bit
to Orrin and then I feel like I didn't
eat the whole thing so the answer to
your question is that it would cost
around $6 per square foot to cover your
house in avocado toast but that's just
the flooring yeah that's not
tremendously expensive flooring yeah you
could find cheaper flooring I think it's
gonna be way more than that I also think
- well I have a couple of couple of
problems on a couple of ideas here first
avocado is one of the fastest grossa
fiying vegetables that exists you mean
it gets big fast it no nope I mean it
gets gross you just mean it gets gross
fast you mean because it goes from green
to that like brownish black and then I
assume a brownish black stage which I
don't tend to experience it gets worse
than that slimy and covered in things
that that are eating it that are very
cellular i right would like to propose
that on the inside of an avocado won't
if there's this the pit and if you could
maybe take an avocado grow it really big
and then sort of like mine your way
inside remove the pit you could just
live inside of an avocado oh that's a
great idea Hank what a solution and then
just if you're hungry you just get a
little salt I'll eat your home yeah and
then it gets bigger as you eat that's a
great idea and then you can just bring
your bread and your toaster into the
inside of the avocado and just kind of
yeah just and then when you have bigger
as you as you consume right your avocado
- and when you win your our friends over
you can say hello welcome to the avocado
oh god I mean it's good til then it was
good till then and then you had to go
and ruin it like you always do because
it's a dome did we get it Hank we've got
we get it it's also a home okay we've
got it I think we've got the full
breadth of the pun I'm sleepy I got home
from Amsterdam two days ago and this is
usually the worst day of my job
and right before starting the podcast
Catherine is like how you doing and I
was like I feel real bad I don't know
what's going on and she's like you have
like tremendous jet lag you are eight
hours off from where you were two days
ago and I was like right yeah that makes
a huge amount of sense thank you for
making me feel better about how
dysfunctional I feel yeah yeah jet lag
is such a new human concept you know
right yeah jets are fairly new human
concept yeah
human bodies definitely were not made to
transition time zones I know I'm not
convinced that human bodies were made
for time zones but the part where I yell
at the people who were defending
daylight savings time is later in the
podcast so let's move on to another
question from our listeners saying this
question comes from Max who asks dear
green brothers my seven-year-old
daughter and I really enjoy the podcast
we listen on the ride home from school
when I pick her up here is her question
seven-year-old daughter question is
there any spice that is smaller than a
grain of salt no D a B Aubrey
thanks again max well Aubrey and also
max yeah definitely right I don't know
is there mom thinking about like
peppercorn is bigger
look oh yeah but they're at like I'm
think I'm like cinnamon cinnamon is just
like like dust no cinnamon is a big
stick well no now it is like at the
beginning but like salt is also not
grains when you mine it or or evaporate
it out of the water it's big huh is is
it did grains when you evaporate it out
of the water I don't know don't not like
that it's like hunks like weird they
have to grind it up they do post
processing of some kind post / - I don't
think salt post Prussian I think Aubree
might know more about this than you do
Hank I I think I think that a grain of
salt is a post production of salt and I
think that cinnamon is a post production
of cinnamon sticks and I think that
nutmeg is a post production of nutmeg
Meg's and I also feel the same way about
paprika which is also very small I I do
I would like Audrey and Max to invest in
like like a cheap Amazon USB telescope
by which I mean microscope and I want
you guys to measure some grains of
[Music]
spices for me and tell me what the
smallest one you find is okay just for
the record I'm salt I I you know what
I'm just gonna I'm just gonna let it
slide and move on and we'll huh we'll
just issue a correction next episode I
think I'm still right oh you're
definitely not right this next question
comes alright this next question comes
from Kevin who writes Dear John and Hank
the other day my boyfriend got a text
from his ex-boyfriend it turns out that
my boyfriend's ex is dating my ex I'm
not exactly sure they found this out but
they invited us out to dinner and Wow
and we accepted Oh I'm torn between I
mean I'm torn between intense curiosity
and totally freaking out what can we
talk about how can we avoid dragging out
old drama why did they invite us out in
the first place Kevin why did you accept
well because they asked it's very weird
to say no when someone says do you want
to go out to dinner saying no is it like
not the normal thing to do the normal
thing to do is to not ask I would say
that the normal thing to do is to say oh
I'm sorry we have plans that night and
then when they propose a different night
you say oh I'm sorry we also have plans
that night because we are a couple is
this any sort of is this is this all
some sort of ploy do we need an escape
plan if things get awkward any dubious
advice on how to plan for this meeting
of the exes would be appreciated a Mont
Assunta montes Kevin yeah
definitely have an escape plan I you
know those are pretty easy to come by
these days you just pick up your phone
and you say oh gosh we have to go yeah
or alternately what I like to do is I
like to schedule a call like I like to
say to my friend like hey make sure to
call me right at 8:15 uh-huh and then I
can either like say like oh it's my
buddy I'll talk to him later
I can say like uh-oh when this person
calls I have to go immediately mm-hmm
mm-hmm
or I like or you could be like I have to
go to the bathroom and then just never
come back yeah I think that might be a
little transparent for the five you're
going for but it's a strategy yeah you
also to bring your boyfriend with you we
have to go to the bathroom and we won't
be coming back just as an FYI that's why
we're taking all of our stuff I yeah I I
feel like this is this is a weird
situation to have your ex dating your
current boyfriend's ex it's seems very
fraught to me it could be a kind of fun
so like maybe you're maybe you're gonna
find out that this is this actually was
a great idea but you're into it now so
just prepare and have some good topics
ready be like you know go to some
websites for for some good conversation
topics when it gets weird and do your
best to not be like remember that time
that we did that thing and then you're
talking about your old relationship in
front of your new relationship which is
never oh it's always either it's a good
story and people are like oh we don't
have stories that good or it's a bad
story and then you're talking about the
badness yeah I would focus almost
exclusively on the present yep and the
future and then on like topics like how
are AFC Wimbledon doing this season is
not only a topic that I would bring up
at such a dinner um
right talk about actually that's
actually the only thing I talk about
when I'm uncomfortable and a lot of
times I've got to get people up to speed
so the first 15 minutes is just me
trying to explain to you why you should
care about this third tier English
soccer team and then I'm like and here's
how it's going and that's it's great
because then people just walk away yeah
I think that is good advice John I think
and I do want an update for how this
went because I don't know that there are
a lot of times in the history of
humanity where this particular thing has
happened
that's a good point Hank it's like it's
more like a premise for a short story
than it is a likely occurrence in real
human lives so I'm interested to know
how it goes this next question comes
from Claudette dear Hank and John prom
is approaching at my school I recently
had a conversation with my friend who
was a boy about it and he said that he
thinks that girls can ask guys to prom I
said otherwise but kept quiet about the
fact that I really wanted to ask him to
homecoming before but literally everyone
said for me not to do it is there an
unspoken rule that a guy has to ask a
girl to prom or is that just an
old-fashioned idea any dubious advice
appreciated Claudette spaghett Claudette
I'm pretty sure that guy was trying to
ask you to prom and just couldn't figure
out how to do it and handled it the
whole situation really poorly probably
saying Oh Claudette I believe that girls
should ask boys to prom pause pause
pause pause no just ask if you want to
ask but the answer to your question is
in my opinion that girls should feel
free to ask boys to prom or girls to
prom and that people should ask people
and that we need to get rid of what you
call all these old-fashioned ideas yeah
I mean is there something to the
division of labor in that at least
people kind of know what's supposed to
happen not really though because
shouldn't you just be able to try to
have these conversations instead of you
know creating all of this false
weirdness around it shouldn't you be
able to I mean it's a difficult thing to
ask like I remember asking we didn't
have a prom but I remember asking
someone to senior banquet I also
remember getting asked to a prom that I
ended up going to and I understand that
it's a difficult like moment because you
don't know if the person is gonna say no
and you don't want to mess up a
friendship there's all kinds of reasons
why it's complicated and fraught and
difficult but basing it on gender seems
to me really like a really bad idea and
I don't like the way that this boy
handled it because I'm almost positive
that he was trying to get Claudette to
ask him to prom but it's I get why it's
complicated but I think I I think
I think you should totally feel free to
ask this guy to prom because I'm 99%
certain he's on board with the idea now
if I'm wrong about that I will send you
I don't know like three bucks yeah
right yeah John was totally send you
three bucks or at least something that's
worth three bucks and just above just a
bunch of Lucroy just like add like two
backs of Lucroy yeah you have no idea
how much consumer goods cost that's how
much a gallon of milk is right a dollar
three dollars I don't actually that is
what a gallon anyway how do you not know
what a 12-pack of Lacroix costs like I
mean there's a lot of things that I've
lost touch with in terms of price
sensitivity for sure but I damn well
know what a gallon of akroy costs again
you could get a gallon jug of Lacroix I
wish the world would be a better place
and they would be less than a minute
gonna go flat so fast Oh Claudette I'm
curious if you were in it like if you're
in a like if you feel like you're in a
place with this guy that maybe he
doesn't want like you feel weird about
asking him maybe ask him to ask you is
that a thing oh just just ask him just
gets just to end the misery that's it's
so the tension is so overwhelming and
then when you finally do it it's like oh
thank god that's over
even if it doesn't work out at least you
at least it's over so I don't know if
John is coming from this from as a
person who and to be clear this is an
anxiety provoking experience but as from
a perspective of a person who
experiences anxiety it may be more
intensely than the average person maybe
I think that I think that there is a I
think that there is a pretty close
connection between anxiety and
excitement and that anxiety experienced
in a certain way can not be pleasant in
the moment but can can lead to pleasant
experiences can lead to a pleasant
sensations yeah we have a different way
to see the world in slightly different
ways no I mean my official that's my
official comment on your comment
Naha no yeah let's move on to another
coin
I am very curious about how people feel
about the connection between anxiety and
excitement because they seem to me to be
pretty elated emotions I mean there's
definitely a connection yeah but I think
it's complicated
this next question comes from Jemma
Hankou writes Dear John and Hank is it
possible that rocks are actually soft
but they just tense up when we touch
them this has been bothering me for a
long time dubious answers are needed
Jemma
I don't gather about this question and
she almost fell over so here's my
question in response at Gemma's question
Hank and I want you to answer it
seriously isn't it possible I don't know
like it can't just be when we touched
them because also rocks tense up when
other things touch them like if you
throw a rock at a rock they they both
tense up that's a good point or if a
rock is just like in the middle of the
earth and it's grinding up other against
other rocks it's still hard so the
question is if Iraq is being untouched
and it's in the vacuum of space and it's
yeah hanging around it's like just a
meteor or an asteroid is it maybe soft
until something touches it and the
answer is maybe who knows maybe it's
really cuddling and it likes to sort of
like cuddle around with itself and feels
all soft until something comes in as
like BookBook but according to our
understanding of how atoms and molecules
work now
right I think the underlying problem is
that we know a lot about life and and
matter at the molecular level that tells
us that probably things like rocks don't
dramatically change how they act when
they're alone versus when they're being
touched it makes them different from us
but there is this weird thing where I'm
thinking about like I'm just thinking
about a rock as being squishy and my
brain accepts that my brain is like no
never it's like oh I don't see that like
river stone being kind of like putty and
like a little bit like squish squish
right no I totally agree and this was
actually a really big question in
philosophy for a really long time does
matter change because humans are observe
serving it and is the world different
when we are looking at it versus when we
are not and which of those realities is
real and right that's a complicated
question I think the this particular
instance of it I think we can deal with
knowing what we know about how molecules
behave and how rocks behave when they're
not near us and when they don't know
that we're looking at them right but
then again it could be that the rock is
so much smarter than us that it's
figured out a way to behave precisely as
it would behave if it were always not
squishy but it sometimes can be squishy
if it wants to yeah
well that also is possible at the moment
you look away from the rocket stops
existing and that everything you aren't
perceiving at any given moment doesn't
exist
unless you are attempting to perceive it
and that the entire universe is just
sort of a blank blackness except for how
it's being projected into your head
including any perception of the past or
in the perception of the future and that
like right now is just a very vivid
hallucination right and in fact the more
you think about how we understand self
and reality and perception the more you
realize that beneath that turtle lies
yet one more turtle and beneath that one
is another turtle until it's today's
podcast is brought to you by the new
book turtles all the way down Turtles
all the way down and not only about the
shifting sands of self and available at
bookstores now just got a really nice
review from Bill Gates and his daughter
Phoebe that did it did I had a feeling
the mentor who you are headed podcast is
also brought to you by gratitude the
feeling of feeling like thanks for stuff
y'all and of course this podcast is
brought to you by a vaca dome avocado
m-- the home that gets larger as you eat
it and finally the podcast is brought to
you by country squares country squares
they're a pastry that fits in the
toaster slot the revolutionising
breakfast forever making children all
across America just a little bit less
also we want to thank one of our project
for awesome donors who paid to have a
message shared today that person is John
Morris who has a message for Steve
Morris John writes I've asked Hank and
John to say a word this word through our
seven-year relationship has remained
ours and has kept us strong I want you
to hear it from those you trust and
admire I hope you continue to draw
courage and joy from this dumb confusing
courageous little word as I will for the
rest of your life thank you and I love
you gar god that's the word gar gar gar
it's a kind of fish I don't know if
that's exactly what they're referring to
well I used I used to catch garfish when
we lived in Florida so there you go
the word is gar Steve and I hope that it
brings you comfort and joy to hear it
good tidings really quickly Hank I want
to note a couple of other sponsors first
my podcast the anthropocene reviewed
which is available three episodes now
available at iTunes or SoundCloud or
wherever you listen to podcasts you can
just type in anthropo because nobody can
spell Anthropocene Ashley Ford just
reviewed the Anthropocene reviewed she
said this podcast is soothing and
informative and somehow perfect to
listen to while you're doing something
creative or doing a task by hand oh
that's very kind of Ashley to say and I
also want to highlight your new podcast
Hank which is so so good delete this
with your wife Catherine thank you we
just recorded last night our fourth
episode and boy John I had quite a week
last week as I was going through my
Twitter feed yeah I had a car accident
and I went to Amsterdam and I released
Mike governor interview video just I had
just a lot of things happen to me and it
was a good old time so we can you know
through that do you ever think Hank that
if you didn't share all the things that
happen to you on the social internet
that they wouldn't be really real um no
in fact would John add well when I said
no I meant yes because I know
wrote a keynote talk that I gave at
patreon about that phenomenon where I
feel like if I like sometimes it's not
like the things that happened to me but
it's the emotions that I experience and
if I feel like I'm an experiencing an
emotion that I don't that I don't want
to or don't feel like I can share with a
social Internet that that somehow
invalidates that particular emotion
oh man that's dark that's deep yeah goes
to it that goes to a deep dark true
place but the great news is that during
the last episode of delete this Kathryn
accidentally referred to Fox and Friends
as the Fox friends and turned into a
really sort of great experience
oh the Fox friends yeah so delete this
is very fun and it's just great to have
a reason to talk to Kathryn for an hour
and a half every week all right so
everybody listen to delete this in the
anthropocene reviewed before we get to
the all-important news from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon we need to go through some
Corrections first from Molly Molly
writes Dear John and Hank just a quick
correction on the most recent episode of
the pod you read a poem from I'm gonna
say his name right now kava Akbar I
happened to go to grad school with kava
and was in a few classes with him his
name
you have been pronouncing it wrong John
you have been pronouncing it wrong this
whole time
even though you are a big fan of his
best wishes Molly she didn't say all of
that some of that is from me so anyway
kava Akbar is a really wonderful poet
and I apologize for mispronouncing his
name this whole time and I'm super
embarrassed and a little bit mortified
then we got several thousand defenses of
daylight savings time all of which were
idiotic every single one is wrong I'm
just kidding that's a little bit of an
oversimplification but I'm going to read
one of my favorites it's from crystal
and she writes this is I thought one of
the more compelling defenses of daylight
savings time even though I'm about to
try to destroy it
Dear John and Hank in defense of
daylight savings time look I used to be
like you I thought daylight savings time
was inconvenient and stupid but then I
moved to Japan which doesn't do daylight
savings time during the sunny month of
June and the obnoxious Sun was invading
my bedroom and rudely awakened me at
4:30 in the morning but still setting by
7:00 p.m. I suddenly realized that the
extra hour of darkness in the morning
was right and good for my soul in the
extra hour of light in the evening was
right and good for my social life I long
to live in a time zone with daylight
savings
I also learned the value of blackout
curtains crystal here's the thing
crystal all that you're telling me is
that Japan is in the wrong time zone I
am not at all convinced that Japan needs
daylight savings time I think it's just
in the wrong time zone the Sun should
rise at 5:30 a.m. and the Sun should set
at 8:00 p.m. I I don't think there's a
daylight savings time problem I think
it's a timezone problem we have a
similar timezone problem here in Indiana
where we should be central time but
we're Eastern Time because of the
stupidest possible reasons that you
could ever imagine anyway all of your
defenses of daylight savings time are
wrong daylight savings time sucks I mean
that's a create like the idea is that
noon is the middle of the day so the Sun
should come up and go down at the same
time that is a very off timezone yeah
it's a very off I agree
anyway I have another question this is
from miss Hyde who asks dear Hank and
John or or responds on your podcast a
few weeks ago a person named Anna asked
if there could be infinite sand on earth
and you instantly replied no because
there's a finite amount of rock on earth
my question is is there a set size for a
grain of sand to be a grain of sand
because if not couldn't the sand just
keep getting smaller in which case we
could have an infinite supply of grains
of sand on earth right dr. Jekyll and
mr. that one there is a size at which
sand isn't sand anymore I don't know
what it is but just have a size I
thought I was gonna learn something but
no all I've heard is that sigh sand
ssize not what that size is what I mean
you know it's it's like saying size but
yeah there's a point at which it isn't
saying anymore and I don't know what
they call it after I think it becomes
clay after that because if you saturated
with water it just it holds on to the
water and molecular Li different ways
but a problem with it the other problem
with that is that even if it was sand
all the way down eventually as we have
learned you can't divide a thing any
further and so if just a single molecule
of silicon dioxide still
did as a grain of sand there couldn't be
infinite numbers of molecules of silicon
dioxide because there are finite there's
a finite number of silicon atoms on
earth a finite number of oxygen atoms
all right there we go you can't quite
have infinite sand Hank I'm gonna let
you get to the news from Mars in a
second but first let me bring you up to
date on the news from AFC Wimbledon gosh
we lost to Shrewsbury 1 nil it was a
pretty close game off things like I
watched the whole game and I thought it
looked pretty close most of the game
Shrewsbury definitely looked the more
likely team to score but they are second
in league 1 actually 1st in league 1 now
since they won that game so it makes
sense that they were probably going to
win however we are now on 42 points
after 38 games there are 8 games
remaining in our league 2 season and
Wimbledon are in 19th place on 42 points
they are now just 3 points there are
only 2 points clear at the relegation
zone and only 3 points separate AFC
Wimbledon from 22nd place Milton Keynes
so the nightmare scenario that this
comes down to the final week and either
the franchise currently playing its
trade in Milton Keynes or AFC Wimbledon
are facing the drop is looking possible
and terrifying Wimbledon probably need
to win two games and draw one or two in
order to stay up I think at this point
but that means getting results some kind
of results from almost half of our
remaining games which is possible but
challenging so please keep Wimbledon in
your thoughts sorry John I I was just
looking through the dust besito music
video and I'm a little worried about the
amount of time we will spend looking at
sideboob I'm not as concerned about that
as I am about the amount of time that
we're gonna be looking at like Justin
Bieber Justin Bieber is oh I gotta tell
you I've never seen I've never seen the
video again I don't think that the video
itself is at all important to the
project it's all about the
level of attention you pay to something
well is Young's from Mars in news from
Mars John the Curiosity rover is spent
it's mm day on the surface of Mars that
landed in 2012 and I cannot believe that
2,000 days man so it turns out that time
continues to pass and curiosity
continues to be able to do its job
remarkably well I feel as if it just
landed yesterday I was over at my
friend's house getting really excited
about it slamming down on the surface of
Mars 2,000 Earth days on Mars to be
clear mm I don't think that I just hit
2,000 Mars days yet because Mars days
are slightly longer than Earth days but
yeah thanks to curiosity for roving
around Mars for a very long time it is
it is an old Rover now and it's showing
its age in some ways particularly on its
tires and certain instruments aren't
working quite as well as they once were
but it's still powered still moving
around still doing its job and it is a
good rover and and it looks like by the
time we get another Rover on the surface
of Mars we will be able to kind of have
it like a continuous transition it seems
like your Assis gonna make it until the
2020 Rover arrives and that's really
exciting
that is really cool that's good to
always have at least one functioning
Rover on Mars that brings me a lot of
hope and enjoy to think that something
human-made is rolling around down there
working at all and that's right that's
right all right Hank what did we learn
today we learned that John for once
thinks that one of my dumb ideas is a
good idea oh god it's such a good idea
it's incredible I've got to watch the
desper see to a music video to fully
understand just how good of an idea it
is but I'm sure that it's excellent we
also learned that it's not a great idea
to tile your home with avocado toast and
we learned that John would like Lacroix
to come in milk jugs and that I have no
idea how much that would cost
and lastly we learned that rocks
probably aren't squishy until you touch
them but who knows I mean generally who
knows anything really it might not even
exist thank you for listening this
podcast is edited by Nicholas Jenkins
it's produced by rosianna halse rojas
and sheridan Gibson our head of
community and communications is Victoria
von Giorno who also runs our patreon at
patreon.com slash dear Hank and John if
you want to go give us some money there
you can get our after-the-fact podcast
this week in orion's it's a very bad
podcast but not maybe not as bad as
analyzing second-by-second every moment
of display seto so thank you to
everybody who supports us there that
money goes to support crash course and
scishow and some of the other things
that we do at complexly the music that
you're hearing right now and the choose
heard at the beginning of the podcast is
by the great gunnarolla and as they say
in our hometown don't forget to be
awesome
[Music]